hello YouTube Ian's this is the Reuben
report i'm dave rubin and we're doing
something different we've already
shifted things after only five or six
episodes we're going with two guests
this time because these people are of
such high comic value and moral fiber
might I add and I thought we could only
fit two of them at the table miss Kelly
Carlin mr. Rick Overton how are you guys
doing fine i'm glad i have full of moral
fiber and you're our first repeat guests
might oh I'm so excited do I get do I
get like a t-shirt or something you will
get something at the end okay good okay
I'm in it for the swag to just get us to
put that out there a mug or sticker
anything and we didn't even give you a
mug at the table while you SAT you think
you're gonna leave here with the mug
okay I'll just get a coffee cup and a
marker pen and write the name little bit
report out on it yeah well you'll get
some sun chips on the way out that'll be
eight hours all I'm asking let's get to
it I feel good about today the Pope did
you know we have a new pope in case you
didn't hear about that on every news
channel endlessly for days it turns out
that can you believe that I just got the
other commemorative plate I got for
which all over again yeah oh so the Pope
how many of those plates do you have by
the way oh they're dating back since
like 1300 yeah that's right yeah the
Pope it turns out that our new pope Pope
Francis might actually be down with the
gays and I don't mean on the down low
with the gays which many of them often
are just down with the gays it turns out
that a couple years ago in Argentina he
told an activist and former theologian
at a Catholic College that he's in favor
of gay rights any favors civil unions he
didn't buy into gay marriage which none
was passed in Argentina but is this
progress Kelly oh well I well I mean if
it was true it would be progress it
would be enormous progress it would be
amazing progress uh so you don't buy
this theologian this guy that works at
the Catholic College who says this well
the thing is that it was a private
conversation you know so he was at the
time it was he a cardinal or
whatever it is so he was you know having
a private conversation but I understand
that in Argentina he was publicly very
much against this law yeah so I don't
know but I you know I love the Jesuits I
think if you're gonna do the Catholic
thing you got to go Jesuit they're
they're intelligent they're very well
educated it doesn't surprise me if he
actually had that personal point of view
about you know gay marriage or whatever
it is so uh uh it would be huge it would
be you know what it would be a miracle
it would be a true miracle Rick could
this be could we possibly have a down
with the gays Pope well yes i am a pope
who listens to the people particularly
the ones taking polls right now you know
I I think he's stuck in a pretty tough
position yeah because the other guys
going start the cars that the car the
wrong to me start the car compactor
stuff forget to forget those clothes
street clothes only we're going we're
getting out there's no shoes given the
different passports will pick one on the
drive and just like I get out of Dodge
dash out of there is what that was makes
me wonder what's coming down that's the
wave this next guys got to stand there
and take when it crashed the beach what
could it be what could well the word is
out that the Catholic Church is a clown
car chuckecheese bounce castle full of
closeted gay guys you know it's jammed
like sardines with them and the right
wing of the right away party any place
that they're both safe houses it's like
nine feet of concrete to get to me once
I'm doing all these bad things with the
big cross in front of me there yeah say
yeah so i'd say like the republicans but
a lot of times you could say when it
when he's mowing the lawn way too much
when he's you know he's going up there
mow the lawn and firing an assault rifle
yeah okay he's gay yeah so is it though
is it a house of cards like if one of
these guys especially now this guy's the
Pope I mean even if he was a little more
okay with the gays does the whole thing
just crumble and then it Out's everybody
and
the whole the whole thing just disappear
it all falls apart one can only pray
you're praying there's miracles and
there's a lot going on here I'm trying
to get in the vibe with this you know
this is this is a institution that had
something called the assessing the
assassins which they use to murder their
own basically so which day yes the whole
Opus Dei all of that and and so I I
don't know I mean they're clearly i mean
it's every institution on the planet
that has been around for over 200 years
is being questioned as being undermined
the Foundation's going away it you know
the Vatican's going to go through some
growing pains I have some hope that this
gentleman because of his his ability to
really connect to people I mean this is
a man who really does take the bus I
really do believe all of that about him
his own moral fiber I think this could
be interesting I think he could push
some reform and and I mean you know
let's face it they're never going to be
lefty progressive I mean it's just not
who they are but if they could at least
participate in the 20th century that
would be exciting yeah be nice what do
you think I mean is it is it possible
that he does do this and they come along
a little bit but isn't it just a numbers
game for them like they can't back
something like a marriage because they
need people to procreate so that they
get the numbers at the church so they
make the money in the day clearly he's a
demographic pie wedge of humanity of
choice that they would spun the lazy
susan the mountain hate us done with us
hate us whoa hang on
here the Hispanic community yet he looks
white because he's Argentine okay we'll
take this little piece of cheesecake and
we'll just dump everything doubles down
on playing that last crowd that gets our
jokes yeah you know I think we can't
work under the other rooms anymore so
that's it yeah it's a Latin America it
is Ricky gave me a perfect segue there
because we're moving from Pope to comedy
to a guy who actually was sort of the
Pope of comedy in America for a long
time and his papacy might be ending i'm
talking about jay leno it looks like
he's out at The Tonight Show and Jimmy
Fallon is going to replace them they're
going to move the tonight show to New
York and there's a lot of ways I think
we can go with this and three comedians
talking about comedy and talk about
other comedians can always be kind of
dangerous so without going to leno
personally or what you think of his
comedy and all that kind of stuff what
do you make of this endless game of the
the tenant you know the chairs of
late-night talk show and and the media
that surrounds just the circus of how it
all eyes out well I mean it was
interesting 20 years ago when the
Letterman Leno thing went down and you
know it's all inside or Hollywood you
know they haven't one wants to talk
about it but the bottom line is is that
NBC is in a lot of trouble they don't
know what they're doing I'm driving
around La seeing billboards of some of
their new shows and I'm like wow that's
the solution a new dating dating show
Wow Oh NBC you're doing great work yeah
so you know they're getting some press
great for them up you know but Leno's
really solid in Middle America he's got
good numbers he's still the leader you
know with all of that so I I just I
think NBC it's just very sad to see this
network do what it's doing and I do and
I think all of this is just a reflection
of their inner turmoil all right well
before we let you jump in here let's
look at the numbers actually because
they're actually fascinating I think
when you think about what's going on
here so leno is actually winning the
slot right now you can see he's winning
the slot he's still winning with the
young people they keep saying well he
only brings in the old people but not
that that many young people are watching
but and also it doesn't 18 to 49 seem
too big of us a huge window 18 to ya one
point when you were yeah where you
hanging out with all the coolest for us
hey my hacking cough so all right let's
go there then so the number I mean did
what all these numbers just seemed
bonkers and what I think of Hollywood I
think of the word loyalty yeah I think
of loyalty dedication honoring that
golden watch at the end of a long and
well deserving tenure yes you know
there's these huge and beautiful
mountains on a range just behind us over
there but no one notices you know why
because they're all is why no one wants
is the old mountains where's the new
glacier right but doesn't it seem
bizarre they're taking a preemptive
strike he's still winning with the young
people and they're still doing this
doesn't that just see water attract is
up anyway yeah so you know I I'd I like
I said NBC that their their their
logical it's crazy I love Jimmy Fallon I
love what he's doing and you know when I
love j 2 j is who he is he's solid I
personally don't watch his stuff but I
don't it's just not my thing but he's
one of the nicest most generous men in
this town yeah a wonderful human being
so that but you know I think it's sad to
that you know they're going to be moving
it to the east coast and there was this
tradition of you know a beautiful
downtown Burbank but you know Carson has
been gone a long time and things do move
on and and I don't know i mean is
anybody really i mean i saw the numbers
there but that's not a lot of people
watching late-night TV yeah its people
are on youtube people are watching
netflix people are you know watching the
daily show people are those are
comparable numbers with tosh yeah yeah
yeah he's probably so yeah now lattice
point and that's burn and all that
because it's on NBC we want to talk
about it but you know what who really
cares yeah when when's the last time
you watched The Tonight Show who every
now and then I'll check in there's a
guest I like or comedian I'm friends
with you know wish they'd be more of
those yeah I think we can all agree to
more comedians on those show that's like
the old days you know what Johnny yeah
used to make make or break a career
Johnny you know I stayed up i was only
and i think i was in like 11 through
tenth grade for the last night of the
Carson Tonight Show judge and I never
stayed up that late was a you know 1130
I was right like I was trying better i
mean and i was in 10th grade early great
all right well good luck Jay whatever
happens we're removing know what he'll
land on his feet he'll be okay he'll be
fine all right let's talk about another
guy that I'm he's having some problems
with poles to Barack Obama the president
was in the Middle East last week and I
actually thought it was a pretty great
trip he he talked about Palestinian
statehood he sways some of the Israeli
fears he got Israel and Turkey to hug
again I thought it all look good but the
polls are just showing the more and more
hate coming out of the Middle East
nobody likes them it's worse now
actually than it was under george w bush
Rick how is this possible Barack Obama
how could this be ah the relentlessness
of a quote-unquote media counter media
that can lie and there's no law stopping
them from doing it and just feed
incorrect data they get everyone
addicted to how they feed it so they're
really defending how that news makes
them feel rather than the beats and the
details right so you're talking about
our media here or you know I'd say a
certain particular Network ah that has
there any reason in overseas overseas
rooted influence ah that is here now
from oh I don't know say Australia well
I'd like to try to how they're gonna
spin because you know as we all know
Barack Obama is a Muslim good so how is
this how is this working exactly right
well you would tell he's the devil from
that artwork on my history is not liking
him right now and he's even got a nice
middle name you know that they like love
Hussein's they love it so I'm really I'm
just fasten I want to maybe I will even
watch Fox this weekend to see how they
spin all of this in their direction yeah
but you know what I don't think it's
Barack Obama
personally I think it is the way that
this region is going down right now
things are once again really falling
apart there there's no stability in the
region there's very little stability and
that's a good thing in some ways but
when you get that you get a lot of
extremists and nationalists and the
Nationalists don't want have anything to
do with America yeah is it is it just
endless because if he can't do it if we
can all agree he's done some good things
I mean you know Turkey and Israel hadn't
talked in five years he got them to make
up so if he can't do it is it is it
truly just no never no hammer first
leader can do it yeah if you're coming
on bum bum bum and you're knocking on
the door with a hammer and they're
looking at the thing and PC you knocking
on the door with a hammer they're not as
willing to open the door right and we
knock everything with a hammer when we
come knocking yeah we let everybody know
who we really are boom boom them a
little bit you know yeah and everyone
now is very wary of us globally because
of that and it was there anything we
could do now would be good what could we
do that would be less having it's like
having a friend who's in crisis you know
until your friend really wants some help
then you know what are you gonna do you
can knock on the door all you want you
know the region is in major transition I
think it's going to take 10-15 years for
the region to figure out what they're
doing the moderates of that region need
to come alive in a democratic way you
know as much as these other groups have
come up in these these tribal you know
rivalries are clearly alive too but you
know the moderates have to come up and
find some consensus then they can reach
out to the big powers like Russia and
America and stuff and get some get some
help that way but you know we I mean
they're part of the reason the regions
in the state it's in is because for the
50 60 years of last century we went in
with hammers and let's construct this
and imagine what the world would look
like right now if there was no oil under
all that dirt enough place be about if
there was nothing we wanted under this
and just saying that's just you know
glassmaking yes infants and magnet yeah
and great tourism I mean you know this
is like where the you know civilization
began the Fertile Crescent such enormous
importance for Humanity and we ignore
all of that because it is all about the
oil so it's all about the oil we all say
that all the time so what so is the only
option we just got to keep getting
greener is that is that what you think
we should do do you have a Chevy Volt
that's what I'm asking ah no I'd like to
get a shady bow tie her to plug it in
but that sounds like a great idea
explore thanks all right I just get a
long cord dude yeah but I'd say that our
culture has to start to wean off
something that's fine height at some
point the sea species has to get away
from a finite thing yeah well to the
infinite thing right well they like
doesn't stop but next we'll be watching
we'll figure out a way we can here at
Monsanto how to boiling but soon enough
it'll need water wars so that's right
yeah yeah we have a quick we have that
to look forward to in the next 90 years
actually I'm pretty sure the water wars
have already started in the Middle East
so yeah I'm pretty sure all the
corporations are buying and this is what
they're doing there but Liz
privatization of water rights that's
what's already going already happening
oh lordy Lou are gonna be governments
you know what after this conversation I
need a little comfort food so let's talk
comfort food did you know unfortunately
it's not as good for you as you might
think of course you know you get
depressed eat some waffles eat some
pancakes you go to mcdonalds etc etc you
think you're gonna feel better after new
studies are proving you actually will
feel worse now I guess in some ways
that's not surprising you're putting
crap in and you're going to feel like
crap but then another way we all do this
right when you get depressed you what do
you do what do you turn to a little
chocolate I hope I have a comfort ometer
and it goes you know not bad cozy
diabetes the American goal for me is to
eventually just be this bloated sphere
with tiny limb buds and a tiny sea of
facial features on the top of the egg
and and I'm being wheeled around in some
sort of wall-e rascal cart to stores
with an opening that will permit me
indoors yeah and that's that to me is
American comfort right there I
definitely sounds like American come
what is your American comfort I've been
to some diners with you in the past so
you can't lie to me here I I do I the
fast food I'm trying to get away from
the fast food right now but it's always
sugar with me Sugar's the comfort for me
yeah and it really it doesn't last long
it you know the idea of it I think is
what lifts your mood and then you eat it
and yes you're right you feel like crap
because you just put crap into your body
and then you worry about you know how
many calories you're just yeah I mean
it's a vicious cycle it's like anything
else now I know that you tweeted last
night that you went to in and out burger
I did and you know I've only been here
for about five weeks so I've gone to in
and out several times and to me that
feels but it literally feels better in
my body than McDonald's but at the end
of the day is that just completely and
that's just the way we rationalize
things well I think they have a slightly
less msg and everyday use real potatoes
and then real tater real picked it was
like what are the Connells potatoes oh
they're like that they're not even
potatoes they're like they change
materially its treated something or
other yeah listen in and out you see
them put the potato in and go what yeah
and the potato comes at the bottom and
that just that process makes you feel
better at least it's a little the steps
in between the food and me there are a
few less steps where as McDonald's I
don't even know if potatoes were ever
even a thought in the french fry I'm
really not sure yeah is this a little
bit like the previous topic like the oil
like we're so addicted to it we just
can't we can't stop well there are there
was someone that would wrestle you to
the ground MMA style if you were if you
were to warn them that a spare a team
was not good for them because they're
going I finally got off sugar onto a
spare a team and now you tell me this
you're taking my one last thing away and
that's how the brain structures all this
you tell the good people with is it a
sperrit a murse part what is that
esperate esperate can you tell the
people what it is because I'm on a stage
race against it it's a Dre bad chemical
that gives you all kinds of kidney
problems and it's in diet it's in every
diets and lots of things and nutrasweet
is another nice way to hide what it is
in the word nutria yeah like there's
nutrition in it yeah very clever we have
our use of utter BS yeah
would you rather go down with some high
fructose corn syrup then do i use
mechanic over in my tea in the morning I
mean that's you know if I'm going to add
sugar if you're going to add a sweetener
i'm going to add honey or actual sugar
to it to it yeah if i'm gonna go you
know and have some crap then you know
you get what you get with that you get
the high-fructose stuff but you know the
thing about comfort food is that this
this it's so funny about the study
because if you just pay attention to
yourself when you're eating this stuff
you will you don't need because he is
like you know it's like it's like the
alcoholic with the alcohol you know it's
like oh I need a drink I need a drink
and then you have it and it's like okay
well I feel good for 10 minutes or my 20
minutes or my buzz or whatever but next
day yeah 20 minutes and the scientists
goes is 20 minutes enough yeah yeah is
that is that what you're you know is it
worth it well speaking of the drinking
policy what'swhat's both your drinking
policy is it is it a glass and a half as
they tell you to have every night or a
man can have to I think right a woman
should have I got it on Christmas Day I
feel really yeah I I had been
self-medicating choosing to
self-medicate and you know instead of
some sort of antidepressant I was using
that which it is a depressant otherwise
but it's I feel great it's not like I'm
gonna quit forever and I wasn't like
drunk or you know like stumbling or
anything like that but I just feel like
my metabolism doesn't need that and my
brain doesn't need that yes I'll have a
glass of champagne and a celebration or
something like that but you know it and
I think people you know you it's really
about paying attention to what is
happening in your own body but we don't
pay attention to anything in this
country yeah Rick what's here what's
your drinking Paula I put it behind me
after mom passed away and so uh I was
doing a little grieving about that and
then I looked at what I do when I grieve
and had a look at myself in the process
and you know figured it out yeah it's
tough though to be in the comedy world
sure I mean I'm you're around pouring
like fountains everywhere around you
yeah but look at you to inet both never
looked better can I just all right let's
move on let's talk about the post office
everyone's favorite office so remember a
couple months ago there was this big
rumor that they were going to get rid of
saturday delivery and everyone went
it was trending on Twitter for days
people are going crazy how am I going to
get my junk mail on Saturdays I've got
to have it well you're not the
government stepped in and they will be
delivering your mail on Saturday so the
idea would have saved the post office
two billion dollars but apparently
Congress wasn't into it and because they
control the post office even though they
don't fund the post office we're getting
Saturday mail back and we're not sure
how it's going to be paid for you need
your Saturday mail don't you oh I stand
by the mailbox on Saturday have nothing
else to do and I'm like is it coming is
it coming is it coming and I'm so
excited when it comes down and it's and
it's more credit card offers and people
offering to refinance my mortgage that I
just immediately rip up and then put
into the recycling bin and is there
anything you want more than that on a
Saturday no of course not I'm you know
I'm thrilled that Congress is finally
doing some good work is this completely
ridiculous I mean we were all okay with
it everyone joked about it were two
three days right but everyone sort of
was like all right what though and we
don't know all the public servants we
know our mail carrier yeah now you're
messing with extended family you're
messing with a field of her to know this
is personal this time you're coming
after my friend that I see every
Saturday if I see that look on their
face like we may not have saturdays and
that's going to hurt my friend not mad
at you and it's as simple as that yeah
we're not as attached to all these other
wonderful public service because we just
don't have this level of daily
interaction with them right but we
should feel this way when any of those
services are being cut away those are
all people they've got to go home and
explain their story to their families to
write but is this an example of like
just the overreach of government sort of
because the post office was willing to
do this you know I mean they were
willing to try to save the money and
then and then the government's like no
no no we don't want you to save the
money this is the government we don't
know you don't have to save money I'm
very confused about this because you
know the big dialogue in Washington
right now is cutting everything so and
here there was actually an agency
stepping forward and and that's
confusing to is like so Congress can
have overseeing the post office but they
don't fund them yeah so what is that
relationship and I'm just curious I
don't know what the rationalization was
by Congress
this I'm guessing it had to do with
personnel or something like that but I
mean my understanding is that a lot of
money every month goes into pensions
future pensions and things like that and
if they if they didn't have to pay that
every month it actually be in the black
they'd be fine so the business I wanna
cut those pensions for the guys that
Rick love so I think that's what you're
saying no I'm just curious about like
the math here yeah the math is almost
completely the artificial math of the
republican austerity push we should
never adopt it ever and we should never
even use their considerations on that
front because all of it's just an
artificial trick to create chaos on on
the other guys watch okay so I like
where you're going with this so do you
think all the numbers when they throw
all these crazy numbers out to you all
the time I mean I was reading this
article and there were bajillion numbers
do you think it's all just nonsense and
everyone manipulates the figure is
either way to just push their thing I
mean who do we trust often is not what
they say it's what they leave out the
fact that these numbers exist does not
mean that the austerity measure was the
only answer to it yeah and that's the
big difference is they're they're posing
these numbers like other things can't be
brought up to make the solution work
later they're saying they are the only
solution they just they're using it just
it makes a raw fear occur yeah and panic
moves and when you panic move you don't
think the situation out very well
alright so even if there is some money
there and it's fear tactics and all that
saturday mail I could let it go we sort
of started with you Colette ago I
actually like it when I used to like it
growing up on Sundays everything was
shut down on Sundays yeah I like that we
stopped doing commerce one day a week
you know this hyper consumerism in this
country is i think is a real problem and
so I think the having the weekend
without mail just from like a kind of
mindfulness retreat sense would be
lovely yeah I don't want anyone losing
their job I don't want anyone losing
their benefits but the world would
continue spinning yeah and what about
the other guys just stepping in fedex
and UPS and autonomy wouldn't yeah that
would then wouldn't they pick up those
other privatization but yeah fedex can
ask whatever they want yeah and they're
not regulated federally for federal
express they're not regulated failure
how did they get that name do you like
the fed itself you know yeah one of
those little dog head tilt but those
kinds of things are certainly the
contradictions we're looking at more
deeply now yeah i mean how about like
you know instead of like a letter
costing what is it 46 cents right now is
it 47 think it's 46 one sense of went up
36 cents to for my letter to go from
here to across town or my letter to go
from here to New York right now there's
no other service that charges the same
amount for that when you're talking
distance and and jet fuel all of that
that confuses me a little bit maybe they
Rick just backed your radical plan to
change the post office all right but do
they put me in charge of this no you
know it's just like the push to make
everything a privatized version of it
just means then they can there's nothing
regulating them that's why they hate
that the actual technical reason most
corporations don't believe in government
as government is a cop watching the
crook right and they just want but what
crook wants the cop there exactly
alright let's talk about everybody's
favorite kooky uncle Vice President Joe
Biden he was in Paris for one night and
I can't ask you to guess how much it
cost because I know you know already won
he was in one room and then you know
Service Secret Service detail a couple
other rooms 585 thousand dollars of your
hard-earned taxpayer money by Joe Biden
was he partying with Charlie Sheen no I
heard it was just the ugly American rate
it was the bad hair blonde rate it was
the ugly American rate they've got a
separate column for that when you check
in yeah and they were like looked at
took one look at him and went oh boy
stick a couple of zeros on them put a
couple of zeros on there is there any
number that's too much lesser get
outraged at this stuff to be totally
fair they had to rent out the entire
floor cuz Joe has no inner dialogue yes
there's no filter he'll just say it and
they have to keep him away from everyone
right and you get a drink in them and
it's like sodium pentathol and the
nuclear the football codes all come out
so it's not even a security issue this
is purely a babbling everyone's his best
friend got to keep them somewhere on the
floor yeah I so want to know I so want
to know how they spent all that much how
could you do it you either one of okay
you're thinking you know those jeroboams
of champagne oh yeah you know you get a
case of the Jeroboam so start with I'm
thinking right you know then the Secret
Service and get drunk I try to shoot the
cord off the top of them when they're on
a pyramid of flutes you know now they
said that the the rooms at this at this
hotel where 900 and night but 900 let's
say you took ya a hundred rooms yes but
that's the little room what happens
presidential suite okay so that's five
grand okay let's say it's ten seats 10
yeah you still you still have a lot of
money to spend 500 500 thousand dollars
i'm thinking i don't know maybe he had
animals come in and just you know [ __ ]
everywhere right and and then the moulin
rouge came in and did can I I die I
think it's impossible to spend this yeah
I don't know what do you think about how
the media treats this kind of stuff
because I sense we're all sort of lefty
progressive types here but if this had
been you know a Republican wasting this
kind of money everyone will be going
nuts right I'd love to see the itemized
hooker tally yeah that actually Secret
Service you know they were like but
fellas we're in France you know that had
to be the conversation that when is this
gonna happen again yeah are hookers more
expensive or less expensive and France
that's what they do well once again it's
the ugly American rate man Americans are
just getting screwed every where we are
nobody likes this is there any country
we can go to now and be thought of
better uh no no but I think of one
canada yo Canadians well I mean they
like their dollars catching up to us
like a pony hey they put up with us nice
don't they politely put up with this
to Australia likes us Australia later
that's true they're kind of even the
uglier version of The Ugly American down
there China pretends not to like us but
they're crazy about us well because
they're gonna cash in the debt one day
that's a [ __ ] they need us to be here
too they're not going to war with us
they're not bombing their own property
exactly just gonna get the Grand Canyon
out and move it take the rocky neck
right you have the sinkhole yes all
right well we went on a slight sidebar
here but I think the point is that Joe
is gonna keep doing these kinds of crazy
things and we just gotta roll with it
and see what I don't make Joe into
someone he's not just make popcorns this
perfect stop stop worrying about it he's
not doing any harm well I have to say
this has probably been the for me at
least the quickest seamless show we've
ever done I don't mean time wise i mean
just sitting here with two people it's
been very nice now I'm gonna let you
guys pimp yourselves out Kelly you got a
lot cooking I do have am cooking up and
uh my weekly podcast waking from
American dream please come join me there
on smodcast calm and I'm on Sirius XM
with another show called the Kelly
Carlin show and I'll be traveling around
the country always with my solo show a
Carlin Home Companion go see it so that
is my pimping thing and Rick endorsed it
Rick what do you got uh we find I've got
a podcast called overview with Rick
Overton on iTunes excellent and that's a
lot of fun and I'm always raising some
sort of heck at at Rick Overton on
Twitter it will be right below you right
now I can look at it the digital what
haha all right well I want to thank you
guys for watching and don't forget
bonobos calm is our official outfitter
they have great new slim fit shirts
don't I look nice and very slim nice and
slim you can answer code TR are 20 for
twenty percent off your first purchase I
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you next week